Disney's descendants just dropped
another sneak peek at the new
descendants movie for new villain kids
are being chosen to attend auradon prep
keep watching to find out who these new
BK's could be is every person here
really evil do they deserve to be here
VK day is coming
Disney has been teasing us like crazy
with all these trailers for descendants
three and on may 31st 2019 they're
releasing the first music video it's
called good to be bad but Disney Channel
decided to give us even more teasers
they released a video showing us a bunch
of new vks on the Isle of the Lost
mal Evie Carlos and Jay are totally the
poster children for turning good and
they have a lot of fans on the Isle they
are choosing for new vks to attend
auradon prep the latest clip from
descendants shows all the new VK is
filling out their applications they're
pumped to be chosen to leave the Isle of
the Lost
let's break down this teaser trailer to
find all the clues there are a ton of
villain kids on the Isle and they all
look so excited at the chance to go to
Oregon life on the Isle of the Lost is
not great the video clip has a speaker
announcing that VK day is today it's the
deadline for applying to auradon prep
and the decision of who makes it will be
made by the original four V Ches
at one point we see a girl with pigtails
filling out her application she says
about halfway through the clip we see a
void filling out an application
his name is bug he says Jay is his
favorite BK then there's another girl
with short purple hair who just wants to
be like now now and the gang are going
to collect the applications and announce
who gets to go to auradon prep who are
the new b ches the video clip doesn't
straight up tell us who the new b ches
are going to be but there are a lot of
clues in this teaser let's take a look
at our first new VK we can see a kid
filling out an application
his name is bug that doesn't tell us
much we know that B case tend to have
names really similar to their parents
but let's look at the rest of the clues
on his application he says he was born
on Halloween in 2010 he was born in
Halloweentown
that gives us two different possibility
for who he is he could be related to a
villain from the Halloweentown movies
these were old Disney Channel original
movies that started in 1998 but most of
our characters in The Descendants
franchise are way more popular than that
the other option is that his parent is
from The Nightmare Before Christmas
Disney now owns the rights to that movie
and if you keep reading the application
it's easy to figure out who bug is
[Music]
Ulises favorite color as burlap you know
like that stuff that potato bags are
made of
well there's one villain made entirely
of burlap Oogie Boogie from The
Nightmare Before Christmas and bug
totally sounds like he's related to Odie
boogie now we aren't sure how a burlap
monster had a human kid but we are here
to judge the other two v case that the
clip highlights are girls and we're
pretty sure one of these is Celia we
can't see the face of the girls filling
out the applications but the reason we
think Celia gets to go to Oregon is
actually in another teaser in the
mystery trailer there is a scene in
Oregon where guards are fighting
something Celia can be seen lurking in
the background she definitely gets to
Oregon somehow and she's going to be
playing a huge role in the movie
she was acting pretty shady in that
whole trailer Celia is the daughter of
dr. facili a from the princess in the
frog we're pretty sure the girl from the
new teaser with purple hair is Celia she
looks like she was wearing a wig
she's got mal posters in a room and
every time we see her she's wearing
purple just like mouth she probably has
magical of abilities that she inherited
we wonder if Celia story is going to be
just like mouths she might get sent to
auradon by her dad to do something bad
but decide to be good anyway
the last two new V K's have got to be
sneeze kids these new characters were
announced last year Smee was the loyal
assistant of Captain Hook in descendents
3 he has two twin boys names for me and
squeaky these two are great candidates
for auradon we aren't sure their father
was actually a real villain sure he
worked for a bad guy but Smee never
seemed evil he was pretty goofy and
honestly he was a pretty nice dude he
definitely wasn't good at being a pirate
squeaky and squirmy also appear in the
mystery trailer they flashed through
really quickly along with dizzy Tremaine
we see them asleep on a couch in auradon
it sure looks like they fall victim to
the sleeping spell uh-oh now squeaky and
squirmy weren't in the newest clip with
all the aisle kids but we know they end
up in Oregon somehow the threat torrid
on mal and the other VIII case feel
really strongly about giving other
villain kids a chance to go to Oregon
and King ven totally supports them
that's why II D gave dizzy a chance to
attend auradon prep at the end of
descendants two but even though they are
trying to do good this is going to be
where everything goes wrong
Disney is good at keeping us on our toes
but we're pretty sure that BK day
happens at the beginning of the movie we
also think that mouths vision will
happen early on before she heads to the
Isle in the mouse darkness trailer mal
and Ben are appearing before auradon
it looks like they might be about to
make an announcement then mal gets her
vision of the sleeping spell and sees
people being turned into stone we think
that they were about to announce VK day
then mal and the other b ches go to the
aisle to select new students we also
know that a barrier breach
happens it looks like that is caused by
Hades on VK day you shouldn't have come
here in the meet the Hades trailer Hades
tries to get through the barrier he
pushes past a whole bunch of kids these
kids are waiting on something from
auradon or maybe they were waving
goodbye to the newest vks this probably
happens on VK day - so how does Hades
end up actually breaking the barrier we
have so many questions who do you think
the newest BK's are let us know in the
comments hit that subscribe button to
keep up with the latest - send in 3 news
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]